so question for some of you guys that  are in sales a lot of times sales people  jump from one product to sell to another  product to sell to another product to  sell oh it's not real no no i would do  better in mortgages no i would do better  in real estate i would do better on  insurance i would do better on this  here's the reality of it to salespeople  listen up very closely your number one  product isn't real estate not loans not  insurance not stocks not whatever you're  selling  nothing's going to change in sales for  you until you realize the number one  product in sales is people the moment  you love people you're interested in  people more than interested in your  check that's when you'll start winning  in sales